la crypte et hortefeux
on y va on est bon
ponctuellement
peugeot matière je rate les deux hommes
atteints
[Musique]
bush
à
or
aho
à voir
c'est qui
bravo au cipecma locales à 11 heures
probablement armé autorisation de tir
est terminée bien reçu
du mit à l'est
me renseigner notre position face à
personne
[Musique]
tu vois quelque chose négative
dernière localisation à 11 heures ici
bravo il faut plus d'informations ça y
est je le vois à blizzard
store and hope in stations
collomb
steam tu m'entends
dieu m'a averti sport
mais on n'approche pas de certitudes
est-ce que j'ai l'autorisation de tir
est terminée
mas ou et mulder sais pas
ici post marc autorisation de tir est
terminée [ __ ] qu'est ce qu'il fait
je demande d'autorisation qui est bordel
nous avons besoin de savoir ce qui s'est
passé hier soir nous aimerions vous
poser quelques questions j'ai rien à
cacher je vous écoute le rapport dit que
vous avez tiré plusieurs coups de feu
combien
j'ai averti sport vous avez demandé
l'autorisation de tirer le cal
potentiellement armé on n'approche pas
de certitudes
est-ce que j'ai l'autorisation tirer
terminé à quelle distance était votre
cible je voulais déjà 10 50 m il se pose
pas autorisation tirer terminé à environ
100 mètres en diront plus - à 100 m je
demande l'autorisation de tirer bordel
que pensez-vous du sergent mulder encore
mon avis petit comté
pensez vous qu'il s'agisse d'un officier
compétent mais c'est vous me direz pas
nulles d'heure vous a donné
l'autorisation de tirer oui on sait tous
que ça s'est pas passé comme ça qu'est
ce que ça peut faire
demande l'autorisation de tirer le
sergent à devoir de répondre tu vois
parce que sinon on a un sérieux problème
pourquoi t'as pas répondu je lui ai
demandé trois fois
vous avez déclaré avoir reçu
l'autorisation de tirer
vous êtes sûr de l'avoir bien compris
évidemment ce sera tout pour le moment